well it seems barely conceivable that a
country in the heart of Europe could be
in lockdown in peacetime this is how it
in these cases have grown over the last
months
slowly at first but now more rapidly
it's a textbook epidemic curve so how
does the UK compare well we may have
well fewer cases and the curve isn't
anywhere near as steep but look back two
weeks when we had the same number of
cases as Italy did back then and the
shape of the curves are very very
similar
so is this an explosion in cases that is
also our destiny we will see many
thousands of people infected by
coronavirus that's what we're seeing in
other countries and the important thing
for us is to make sure that we manage
those infections and make sure that
those individuals who are most affected
so are elderly people particularly those
with chronic underlying conditions get
in touch and get treatment and we
support other people in the home
environment it doesn't mean that death
in the UK will match those in Italy here
18 percent of the population is aged
over the age of 65 in Italy it's 23
percent the oldest population in Europe
and as we know the elderly are more
vulnerable to serious disease so deaths
in the UK could be lower but the
increase in cases has raised questions
about the action the government's are
taking France and Germany have a few
hundred more cases than the UK where we
could perhaps be in four or five days
yet both countries banned gatherings of
more than a thousand people at the
weekend here the government says the
time isn't yet right to restrict contact
between people because for now the risk
is too low to justify the disruption but
the government isn't sharing that
evidence with us it stopped releasing
information last week on how many UK
cases a catching the virus here rather
than bring it in from abroad by contrast
in Singapore the public is given full
details of the links between individual
cases where they picked up the virus and
their condition in hospital but cases in
the UK are doubling every two or three
days and some attempt on
social dis ting to slow the spread of
the virus can't be far away